Starting now starting cycle.
So it should actually.
Okay,
so it should be explored and it should
actually record everything at the action
level.
Okay, this is actually create first goal.
The second goal is it should actually
collect important items and like all in
with you.
It could be a bug or it could be a doubt,
what not.
Sure.
The 3rd thing is actually it should be
able to like create a knowledge base out
of your alignment.
Yeah.
It is a the knowledge base is a product
of you and the agent,
and it should be able to consider the
knowledge base for further distance,
Yeah.
whether or not to align on something or
whether like whether or not to escalate
Okay.
something.
Isn't lets see if there is a repeating
bug, the instruction could be escalated.
No.
Yes,
give it actually like have the highest
priority are there is a really frequent.
It can actually report that to you.
So these 3 things it has to do initially,
the rest we will figure out.
Yeah.
Okay, so it should explorer it,
it should record everything at the action
level, collect important items like bugs,
doubts,
create knowledge base with on its own,
also talking with me too,
like with the human.
And consult the knowledge base in the
future sessions and lets say if there is
Haan.
a frequent bug,
it should like reported like this bug is
happening again and again.
And the other thing I missed one part
Yeah.
before this frequent bug.
In the which I will take it from the
report,
What is the other thing?
I will check it from the recording.
It said something before frequent things.
You are recording.
Before frequent, no, it should escalate.
When it actually.
Yeah, this escalation part,
what does it mean in this context?
Essentially,
it should give actually more priority the
next time around when a report comes,
this particular thing actually should be
shown to the first item.
What particular thing escalate what
issues?
Whatever if the escalated one escalated
issue, escalated issue, doubt, question,
whatever it is.
Basically,
actually the knowledge base it creates,
it helps.
It helps it for actually 2 things.
Hello.
Basically,
the knowledge base helps it like control
the other 2 flues.
What to record, what not to record.
For example, even in recording,
it doesn't have to like, let us say,
record the mundane flues again and again.
Mhm.
Or else like it could record,
but it does not have to act on it.
Yeah, knowledge base will say itself,
say its a high priority or a low priority,
So let's say like there's a new level.
low priority happening again,
we don't have to do anything on it.
So it will simply say low priority bug
found again,
but not like push it on the top,
that kind of thing.
You are right,
like that is one and it like basically
the knowledge base will help it like help
me take many actions. Basically,
Okay.
it is a historical action like basically
it uses its memory. Basically,
this is the memory part.
This is the memory part that controls its
behaviour.
The first 2 does not control its
Right.
behaviour.
The first is actually record of just
actually what happened.
It will not actually base its future
decision based on the first set of
records.
The second thing is a set of records to
Mhm.
align with you.
The 3rd thing is the findings like which
will influence future behaviour both
during exploration as well as reporting.
One knowledge base where everything is
like recorded,
other one is they like temporary memory.
No, it's not knowledge base. Like we have,
we have actually no,
Thank you.
let's say like we have 3 3 datasets. Okay,
one is actions.
No.
Okay, actions along with evidence.
OK,
it would be essentially an image or lets
say like a like a lets say like a an
error log or something like that.
Ahh.
So one is actually actions with evidence
that helps us understand what was done.
Hello.
Not.
Okay,
and actually the second table is what has
Haan.
to be discussed.
Haan.
The 3rd thing is what is remembered or
what should influence future behaviour.
What is?
These are the 3 datasets.
Remembered and well impact feature.
Influence in future behaviour, yeah.
Okay.
Right.
So the idea is imagine that actually we
ask it to compare actually the
screenshots given particular actions and
report when the when something when the
change actually does not make any sense.
Okay, let's say like without,
let's say without memory,
let's say if it compares actually 2
screenshots, okay from 2 different runs,
let's say in between actually we moved a
button.
Okay, it can simply put the button,
but the button is rendered in the wrong
place.
Mm.
But when we chat with it,
if you tell it that...
Like we have actually made some changes
to the UA buttons are moved here and
there, now we do not consider the symbol.
Basically,
known known working state of the app
Other knowledge list can be the known
factor, not just working study,
should be there.
it could be many things.
Basically,
that is actually like why I imagine that
actually you actually you have a junior
under you who is actually supposed to do
regression testing for you.
Yeah.
Okay,
first actually like whenever actually the
first data set we were discussing is kind
of a snapshot that is automatically taken
by the machine they use.
They work with go dot go dot records
Yeah.
actually water like where did they move
their mouse where did they click to what
was the screen at that point in time.
So it is something automatically created.
Okay,
the second thing is actually something
they create actually like manually when
they when they think there is.
Something important to discuss.
Hello.
Basically, I clicked on the button,
the button did not work.
I had to click on this 3 times to make it
work. Those kind of things.
First thing is actually like done
mechanically by the underlying layer.
Okay.
I am just giving you examples.
It can do it mechanically,
Right.
it can do it or like it will be good or
can do it or the agent itself can do it.
But the first is record a set of actions.
The second is.
No.
Set of important items that you are you
today have to discuss.
The 3rd is the knowledge the it
accumulated okay,
basically the important decisions that
are made.
Which will which it will use to control
its further action.
Let's say you ask it actually not to
let's say like test anything under
testing lists.
Actually,
let's say like it's actually testing a
dev build.
It actually tests every level in every
every playlist.
It actually starts actually reporting a
lot of volatile items.
Okay,
from our level under development playlist.
Are you following?
Yeah.
Repeat it.
No, basically, so lets say.
I As soon as you asked me now,
I lost the thought.
So I was thinking also when you said you
it should be not like giving things based
on the development levels, right?
If that part, now I got confused.
Yeah, it should not,
but how will it know it?
So lets say first time actually. Yeah,
but how will you like when will you tell
We have to done it.
it?
When it asks.
so when it builds,
lets say it actually figures out actually
like lets say it played a level, OK,
it actually figure figured out 100 bucks.
Yeah.
There is no point in earning 100 bucks.
Basically,
Yeah.
it has to say that actually this level
actually contains a lot of error.
Then you tell actually like these levels.
Thank you.
Under that particular playlist,
our development levels,
we don't have to revision test it.
Yeah.
Now it has to record this somewhere so
that the next time around it conducts the
testing,
it uses this knowledge base either to
avoid testing the level at all or else
understand that actually it is a known
issue which we do not have to care so
that it does not report to you.
So this is the 3rd table is the
conservative memory.
Gotcha.
This is a structure I am imagining.
You can actually get the transcript and
you can actually ask you to read in it
further.
Yeah.
I have my notes too.
I'll like the earlier discussion we had,
Like that would be.
the I'll take this one as a transcript
too. I will create a.
Yeah,
come up with let's say final solution on
what has to be done.
Yeah.
Okay, anything else?
Okay, I know I'll do it later in email.
I have like merger one of one or 2
branches in GD Math.
We'll do it and then.
Who How good are things going with a EN
Akshmai in developing good earth?
Are you actually going in cities or?
So there are teeny tiny issues,
teeny tiny issues like lots and lots of
comments. That's the issue.
Other issue is there were implementations
which I reviewed basically.
So what happens if it doesn't respect.
Give me one minute. Give me one minute.
Our structure.
Hey, tell me, ma'am.
So,
like it's changing the code as it likes,
it is fixing the bugs,
like there are like good things too.
But there are some things it is modifying.
So lets say we have a pubsub where all of
Okay.
our signals are just a single signals.
There is no what is it argument in it
Multiple signals, yeah.
started adding arguments to the signals
too.
We have to just tell it,
this is how we do it and you can actually
give a reason to.
But like the reason for adding the signal
was to fix the issue that we had long ago,
basically long in the sense in some areas
we do accept expect the argument.
OK.
But we our signal does not have it,
so in order to fix the bugs,
it have fix the signals.
Things are working, it is following like.
Its fine if it is changing the structure.
Structure, it is not changing too much,
but it is not following our if else
No, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter as long as as long as
policy and all like.
like you do not think actually like those
are actually stupid changes which will
break things. It is fine.
Yeah.
so like we we'll have to do some human
review little for some time,
then if things are like fine,
like if like it's good enough,
Nothing.
then like we can.
the problem is actually she will not be
able to do it, am I right?
You will be able to do the reviews.
so I told her to do the review with the
AI first, some higher model,
not just like medium or even medium can
do the review with the differentiation.
Yeah.
Just ask it like compare the branches.
What is the change? Tell me,
Yeah.
like what have you changed? Like what?
Things are changed,
it can answer on its own.
No.
And if let's say you find something
random,
Hi.
like why this file is there because like
you have gone through 4 iterations.
Thank you.
Yeah.
In one of the iterations you change 20
files,
Hi.
but only you used like 10 file changes
and that other 10 are just a leftovers.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Those things should not be there.
So either it could be part of our agents.
md file like leftover should not be there
or we have to clean it up later on.
Nah.
The easiest approach would be to add the
instructions the agents.
Yeah.
md if it still not following it.
And.
We will like have a one review sessions
wherever before merging any branch,
Okay.
we will have a review session.
Okay, ma'am.
And it's not that costly either like 0.
0 numbers to review like get the only
Okay.
review the difference between 2 branches
for a feature.
Yeah, understood, understood, understood.
And it doesn't have to be like only like
a if it could be other things too.
But anyway, involving an expertise, Sir,
Yeah,
so when we say like diff in the sense
good idea.
like this is the feature branch,
this is the main branch,
Connect.
what it is in have added,
review things for me,
act as a senior tester or good or
developer or something.
Say it again.
So basically,
like I simply start with the capital case
things, I write it in caps,
act as a senior good or developer,
review this branch with the main like
compare this branch with the main branch
and review the fee.
Yeah,
it changes the implementation and give me
the summary.
It can simply get this very easily.
Yeah,
it looks like actually you do not
And it's fairly readable summary.
actually see anything dangerous,
so let it continue our shoes.
I didn't see that much like basically
apart from what is it the little bit of
code style and writing too many comments.
I don't see anything that breaking and
And.
Nice.
they also the testing they also did they
tested like Soumya.
Karthik, what is it? Who is it?
I got Sarika and Unajame,
all 3 tested it that things are working
on the device. They took a bill in check.
Okay, Sanya.
That is good enough. If it is working,
that is fine.
Yeah.
Okay, they eligible.
Okay.
Okay.